[Music]
chapter 12 of ursula k le guin's third
earth sea novel the farther shore is
entitled the dry land and this has a
particular significance you could say
in not only the geography but the
metaphysics of the earth sea universe so
it's not dry land like the land of the
islands this is in fact the land of the
dead or at least the majority of the
dead as we will find out a little bit
later on
and it's an idea that we've already
encountered previously
in the word of unbinding that that very
first earth sea story and in a wizard of
earth see where ged has to cross into
the dry land to try to save a dying
child almost getting caught there in the
process himself and so the dry land is a
dangerous place in many respects for the
living a mage can cross what's called
the wall of stones and come back across
still living anybody else is pretty much
stuck on that side and sometimes even
mages might not be able to cross back we
find thorian the summoner stuck there as
they run into him in this story as well
and we learn a good bit more about the
dry land in this story than we've ever
learned in the previous earthsea novels
so
ged and lebanon are in right
cross over the wall of stones this is
the boundary point that the dead cannot
cross of their own accord only by being
summoned back
into the world of the living as has
happened in the earlier chapters and has
happened in other parts of the earth sea
saga
they cross the wall of stones this is
them going into the land of the dead
this is going into a land in which there
is no change one of the really
graphic ways of depicting this is
um
it was like a late twilight under clouds
at the end of november a dour chill dull
air in which one could see but not
clearly and not far
aaron knew the place the moors and
barons of his hopeless dreams but it
seemed to him he was farther immensely
farther than he'd ever been in dream he
could not make out anything distinctly
except he and his companions stood on
the slope of the hill before them was
the low wall of stones they step over it
and he says overhead where aaron thought
to see a heavy overcast of clouds the
sky was black and there were stars he
looked at them and it seemed as if his
heart shrank small and cold within them
they were no stars he had ever seen
unmoving they shone
unwinking
they were those stars that do not rise
or set nor are they ever hidden by any
cloud
nor does any sunrise dim them small and
still they shine on the dry
land
so
this is you know
quite disconcerting
he doesn't know where he is other than
he's in the land of the dead
and what's really interesting about this
account is we find out that the dead
have a kind of
what could we call it community
something that imitates the
life among the living
we have houses
we have other things like this
so he says it seemed they walked down
the hill slope a long way but perhaps it
was a short way there was no passing of
time here where the wind where no wind
blew and the stars did not move they
came then into the streets of one of the
cities that are there and aaron saw the
houses with windows that are never lit
and in certain doorways standing with
quiet faces and empty hands the dead
the marketplaces were all empty there
was no buying and selling there no
gaining in spending nothing was used
nothing was made gad and aaron went
through the narrow streets alone though
a few times they saw a figure at the
turning of another way
distant hardly to be seen in the gloom
at the first of these aryans started and
raised his sword to point ged shook his
head and went on darin saw that the
figure was a woman who moves slowly not
fleeing from them
so this is you know quite interesting
why should there be houses why should
there be towns why should there be
marketplaces we also find out too that
these are
kind of unusual you know there's a lot
of dead
everyone who's ever died is there
but the land is vast and so you can walk
a long ways without encountering
anybody unless you go into one of those
towns
and
there he says that
the dead spirits are healed of pain
and of life
it's interesting to think about that is
life is something that you are healed of
and in a certain way this prefigures
what has happened to cobb right
so
healed of pain you know the dead are not
these horrifying figures that we see
in movies
you know where uh we go down into their
land and their their skull faces or
anything like that no they look like
ordinary people and the things that have
been damaged uh with them are not uh as
we say loathsome not frightening quiet
were their faces
freed from anger and desire there was in
their shadowed eyes no hope
now he also tells us
rather aaron
realizes
the dead have
no point to their existence they just
are they are simply being
and there's really no direction there's
a couple ways of
of looking at this so
he's rnc is a mother and child who have
died together and they were in the dark
land together
but the child did not run nor did he cry
and the mother did not hold it or ever
look at it those who had died for love
past each other in the streets the
potter's wheel was still the loom empty
the stove cold no voice ever
saying
nothing happens none of these things
that
do in fact define us or characterize us
a potter remains a potter but makes no
pots and doesn't seem to
care about that a little bit later
we find out that
here we go it seemed to iron that in
this timeless dust there was in truth
neither forward nor backward neither
east nor west no way to go
was there a way out he thought how
they'd come down the hill always
descending no matter how much they
turned and in the dark city the streets
went downward so that to return to the
wall of stones they need only climb and
at the hills top they would find it but
they did not turn
they came out onto the city the country
of the innumerable dead was empty no
tree or thorn or blade of grass grew in
the stony earth under the unsetting
stars there was no horizon
there is nothing to to
actually look at there's these mountains
and there's high peaks weathered by no
winter rain no snow to gleam and
starlight
and
what we find here is that aaron goes
through some emotional
reactions
passions really
he begins with fear
and then
that transforms
instead of fear then great pity rose up
in aaron
and if fear underlay it it was not for
himself but for all people for
those in the land of the dead and those
yet to die he sees that the mother and
the child
the lovers
there's no connection between them
anymore
and so he feels
pity for them
then we encounter you know the coldness
weariness
and eventually aaron just feels
desolation
in this land of the dead as a living
person
they come eventually to the dry river
and at that point they run into cobb and
cobb tells them
well
you're not going anywhere else from here
right
ged says we've come too far to turn back
and
a voice in the darkness says you have
come too far iron answered it saying
only too far is far enough you have come
to the dry river said the voice you
cannot go back to the wall of stones you
cannot go back to life
and god says well not that way. and then
they have this encounter with with cobb
cobb tells them that he has found
immortality he says i have no fear what
should a dead man fear and get in his
first response says well you seem to be
awfully afraid of death aren't you
and
the
person says
i have i live my body lives right
and he says i can mend my body i know
secrets of healing and youth no mere
illusions
i alone among all mages found the way of
immortality which no no other ever found
and ged says well maybe we weren't
looking for it and then here it's kind
of interesting he
cobb or whatever this this thing is
is very cynical about it he says well
you didn't find it because you didn't
look for it because you were afraid to
or you did try to find it and you didn't
and i'm so much smarter than all of the
rest of you i did the the thing that
none of you could do i'm the only one is
very solipsistic in the end i'm the only
one who truly lives i'm the only one
who matters
he says
would you like to know how i did it
archmage and he says i was in palm after
you thought you'd humbled me you taught
me a lesson but not the one you meant to
teach i said i have seen death now i
will not accept it let stupid nature go
it's stupid course i'm a man better than
nature above nature i will not go that
way notice what he says next i will not
cease to be myself
and now pause on this in a moment and
the dead
are they still themselves well this is a
really great question
if we think about what it means to be
you
there's a certain you that survives in
this land of the dead right the potter
as we mentioned remains a potter
but doesn't practice their art
the looms stand
empty the mother and the child don't
relate to each other any longer as
mother and child in any
living way
only a frozen dead way lovers pass each
other
on the streets if that's part of what
makes us us
something has been lost and a little bit
later get is going to
say to cobb
uh here we go when the bot when my body
dies i will be here but only a name in
name alone in shadow do you not
understand did you never understand you
who called up so many shadows from the
dead who summoned all the hosts of the
perished even my lord earth aqba wisest
of us all did you not understand that he
even he is but a shadow and a name his
death did not diminish life nor did it
diminish him he is there
there not here here is nothing dust and
shadows there he is the earth and
sunlight the leaves of trees the eagles
flight
he is alive and all whoever died live
they are reborn and have no end nor will
there ever be an end i'll save you so
now it's interesting because he's not
saying oh well aerith ecbo is
reincarnated into a squirrel or this guy
living over here or anything like that
he's just saying no
there's there's a difference here the
the shadow whatever this is the the name
has survived in the land of the dead and
it has agency of a certain sort it just
never exercises that
on its own
and then
the life
remains within the world of the living
and you
cobb
have forgotten that and cannot master
that
you can kill me and my body can die on
the shore you know of celador
but
even if you bind me here you're only
going to bind my my shadow and my
my name
coming back to cobb cobb tells us
that what he did is is go beyond the
pelnish lore which was about summoning
the dead to
create an even greater spell and this is
what has caused the crisis and
catastrophe that is affecting earth he
says i took the pelmish lore again but
found only hints and smatterings of what
i needed so i re-wove and remade it and
made a spell the greatest and the last
and god says oh in working that spell
you died and cobb says yes i died i had
the courage to die to find what you
cowards could never find the way back
from death
i opened the door that had been shut
since the beginning of time and now i
come freely to this place and freely
return to the world of the living
alone of all men in all time i am the
lord
of the two lands and the door i opened
is open not only here but in the minds
of the living and the depths and unknown
places there being where we are all one
in the darkness they know it the living
know it and they come to me and the dead
too must come to me all of them for i
have not lost the majory of the living
they must climb over the wall of stones
when i bid them all the souls the lords
the mages the proud women back and forth
from life and death all must come to me
the living and the dead i who died and
live and he says well where did where is
it that you are and he says between the
two worlds
so there's a between space between life
and death
that cob
inhabits
he is the lord of both
worlds and of this in between or at
least this is how he
presents himself to to get to the
dragons to all the dead to all the
living as the king as the immortal one
and get is going to reveal to him
things are not exactly as he thinks uh
not only does he tell him that you know
the debt are simply these these you know
shadows and names he also says a living
body suffers pain cub a living body
grows old it dies death is the price we
pay for our life and all life
and
screwing up with this right and he asks
him what is your actual name
cobb can't figure out what his own name
is he's lost that in the process all
he's got is cobb his old use name and a
bunch of titles the immortal one the
king you know the lord
but these aren't actual names he doesn't
know himself
any longer he actually tells them you're
not real you have no name only i exist
this solipsistic point of view again and
ged says you exist
without name
without form
you cannot see the light of day you
cannot see the dark you sold the green
earth and suns and stars to save
yourself but you have
no self
all that which you sold that is yourself
you have given everything
for
nothing
all you're doing is trying to fill your
emptiness
and the last thing that he that cobb
tries to say is his name is life
and
dead says well i would give you life if
i could but i can't you're dead i can
give you death
and we can bring this to an end you can
be one of these inhabitants as he's
going to do
shortly
after he heals the wound between these
two worlds
so cobb
has
drastically altered things and destroyed
you know so much in the process
including his own
self
so
a lot going on here in this discussion
of the dead once we see our main
characters crossing the wall of stones
to go find
what damage has been done and try to
undo it within the dry land
you